yeah
here he comes um if your child makes one
of these get him tested don't turn your
back on that child
hi american people i was trying to
subtly do it you see a man looks like me
he stole a lot of toys out of this store
and all for you kids who don't know what
star wars is get up all the stuff see
this has everybody
i like you because he was a brother
yeah he's only brought the movie so they
got really deep
now how do you know he's a brother you
never see anything the costume says it
all oh it was james jones voice we know
what's happening we know what's
happening so you've never been out of
control about a toy that you can
remember
the white power ranger i was in this toy
store and two men were on the floor
choking each other
over this power i swear choking it was
like 100 people in the store and for a
split second i said i go snatch that toy
while they're fighting
that's what i was thinking but i'm
sinbad no no it's me
if it wasn't me i could jack both of
them up because they're on the ground
and i could have had that white power
ranger been out there right but what i
ended up doing that was just as sick as
went to toys r us
and told the guy when's the shipment
coming he said tomorrow morning i said
page me at 7 00 a.m i was behind towards
our house with a jeep and the guy was
bringing me boxes of white power rangers
but all these other people who was
coming stuck like that sinbad they took
all the power rangers i know it wasn't
me and i drove to the airport with about
20 white power rangers i made more money
oh oh i sold them
white power raiders went for 300
you'd have done it i don't feel bad hey
everybody these two are looking for a
turbo man
what's up man well i want to just talk
about the turbo man dog yes
you broke it static
you leave it just like that somebody
shows up
and put it by a little kid has ever seen
one ah this like it's so funny
it's it's so funny
it's mean but it's funny uh this is
great this woman's back mae jemison man
first woman with his face face scientist
bad woman and fine too
what arnold does he messes with you
uh-huh i'm gonna walk over like this
i haven't been at the gym heavy
so you find yourself going man so you
find yourself trying to tighten up i
don't know why you look at this hey
what's up man
just trying to stay tight not to mention
relatives sending presents they're gonna
have to send back anyway how many
toiletry kits does a man need they're
about to go stupid letters from kids to
santa at the north pole this man could
you send me a bike in the slinky no your
father's been laid off if your kid came
to you and said dad i must have this
particular
toy it's hard to find
see it's possessed you don't have to
touch nothing